i don't trust reviews on websites that
aren't like a third party's website
you know what i mean even some
third-party websites right like even
amazon they're all [ __ ]
right like and especially if it's on
your website but i don't trust your
review
five stars no way it's on your website i
just don't trust amazon reviews in
general like especially in japan
there's i mean we've talked about this
before right yeah but
i mean that's why uh they have like the
certified seller thing a certified uh
buyer bought it which makes more sense
yeah um we need more people like maelyn
with the hard opinions
i'm a [ __ ] reviewer because i don't
really give a [ __ ] as long as it does
the thing
i i don't care some people could have
written a review for like a whole thing
or anything
yeah i'm always five or one star i'm
that guy i'm that kind of guy
because that's the tim might see me it
either works or it does yeah
and like if it looks fine fine that's it
if it does the thing i paid for it to do
five stars that's great those [ __ ]
were like
two out of ten the box was bruised like
people people like rate furniture
and they're they're like it was
complicated to build uh two stars and
i'm like
but that's truly that's just like that's
on you bro yeah i feel like that's
that's a
interpretation thing like is the thing
good yeah at the end of the day you're
only going to build it for like one hour
or two hours or so there are some times
when i'm just like how
like i'm pretty sure you need a phd to
translate okay this
ikea there's is like one thing i know
what you mean but at the same time like
my okay i have a coffee table right now
that was
so over engineered and the amount of
screws and [ __ ] for it was
totally stupid yeah that was three hours
out of like the two years i've been
using it
i don't give a [ __ ] about those three
hours looking back now that's why i
write the review like three months after
i get it because then i'm like
oh yeah it's good it's just still
standing that's why i wait if it breaks
after like one month all right fine but
that's one star i shouldn't have broke
one month
if i use it but like people these people
who write it and they're like
um the cardboard box was slightly
damaged you know the furniture took a
little longer than i'd like to it like
[ __ ] off the delivery man had a bad
attitude like [ __ ]
it's got nothing to do with anything and
then as well even if it breaks i'm like
alright how long
reasonably did i expect it to last like
my bed's broken is that
but it's two years is that he also spent
like 100 bucks on it
it was oh it has 300 bucks for the
mattress and the bed
which is very cheap for a bed
considering how much we've spent
uh like on amazon to get like our first
furniture i think
the furniture i have right now has
lasted very well um
my bed is like the this design of this
bed is when i was building it i'm like
huh this doesn't seem
super structurally stable i understand
why i was three stars now
yeah yeah well basically you know that
meme with the cheeto in the door holding
the
door closed there's like a tiny plank
like a piece of plywood
that basically is like holding up the
middle of the bed and like all the way
on it
that doesn't sound safe no and uh
once you stood on that and jumped on it
would just crack right well one time i
i think i like just like like because i
don't know i i wouldn't say i get into
bed aggressively
but i'm not like i'm not polite about it
you're not gonna be like
i'm not like i'm not like like sneaking
into my bed you know i just kind of like
you know just
fall and just like [ __ ] does a
clothesline on the bed or something like
that
no so i just like popped on my bed and i
just heard the boom
and then and then i like looked under my
bed and this thing had just like
like [ __ ] went lit to the side and i
was like oh that's her ass it's not even
screwed in
no no it's literally just like put in
with the weight
just a plank of like like literally like
if this is the bed make sure i don't
trip the
like it's just like this you've got to
like center this piece of wood
it's literally engineering it's
literally like this size as well oh my
god
and so when i when i i looked and it was
like this right i was just like oh sorry
so just like
[Music]
so i do that every time it does it now i
mean that's that that works right that's
what you're talking about
yeah probably time for a new bird i mean
you're moving soon gonna yeah i'm gonna
upgrade
your breads which bread
yeah you can feel the springs on it and
everything right now can't you i kind of
like filling the springs there
why really it's got a nice feel to it
you know i know does that mean there's
no one else someone someone else is like
i like feeling a little bit something
like people looking around the room not
a single person is like
yeah it sounds like that sounds like
peasant talk to me okay i'm
shocked
no king wants to feel the springs on the
bread connor um
what is your obsession with bread yes i
don't want springs in my [ __ ] bread
that would be really awkward when i'm
trying to cut it um
the knife keeps bouncing it's just um
well i you know when i go to a hotel i
have their amazing
you know [ __ ] whatever their little
hippo is the brand i don't know what it
is sleep easy
anti-gravity mattress or whatever the
[ __ ] it's the hippo it's like sleep easy
the brand i think it's a hippo
brand anyway it's like some deluxe
divine 10
000 sheep i'm like oh that's pretty good
this it's great that but also
those beds are ridiculous and like i
don't
i don't think they're that much better
than a shitty bed
i don't know i don't know about that one
chief
you know you know a [ __ ] mattress when
you're on it yeah i i had a
i had a memory foam one at my parents
house i don't like memory foam ones
those ones i don't like so yeah i love
those when i first well yeah it's
because you gotta break it in like you
really
like after like a year it's like amazing
it's like putty you just like
sink yourself it takes like months for
it to like actually get the right shape
but then it's amazing
i want to see like feel some bounce on
it with with the memory foam one it
feels like i'm sleeping in quicksand
where you just sink in and you're just
like oh yeah that's the thing though
like the comfort envelopes
but i feel like the thing is you know i
mean uh i feel like that's like
admitting you're just single if you get
a memory foam one
because it's like it's not it's not an
exciting bed you know
what do you mean do i need to explain
god please there's no bounce
i gotcha i mean it's just depressing
it's it's it's
it's like [ __ ] on a bean bag you know
i mean i don't i don't use memory foam
beds so i say you go then you know what
i mean
have you ever seen that because i i like
the bounce i i mean i like to bounce
normally when i'm sleeping you know
what are you [ __ ] sleeping like this
do i really need to explain this come on
i get it i get it
sometimes you know sometimes you just
want to play a bit of basketball right
you just want to dribble some balls
sometimes you need to like dribble you
know what i mean
can you catch my drift guys
but like spring bread's like awful for
that they they're they are
good you can use this same bread
there didn't i you literally said stupid
bread oh my god
i have to kiss god go to the bakery
have you ever slept on a water bed
before i imagine that must be fun
that's really fun it's like literally is
that actually fun is it comfortable
it's really okay i find it to be super
[ __ ] comfortable but that's because
again it's like
it's but i find memory foam to be really
comfortable so it's kind of like that
because like
the the mattress kind of follows you as
you're moving around
but then like if you're if you're like
in a if you're like you become the match
you get a double memory foam mattress so
you guys are like never going to touch
each other you guys are going to be like
we have our we have our crevice it is
set
yeah that's why that's what i don't like
about the memory foam mattress yeah
that's what i think
it's a single single bed there's no
movement i'm not seeing enough movement
anywhere on a memory foam mattress you
sink in and that's just it
that's what that's what couples do when
they like agree that they're just not
having sex anymore